Looking back at the 19th century,
it's possible to say that the extreme
popularity of serial novel,
the novel released in installments over
time was inevitable in London,
changing economics.
We're creating the perfect conditions
for this to happen.
Thousands of people were moving into the
city.
Literacy among the lower and middle
classes was increasing.
A new printing and distribution
technologies were coming into their own,
but the magic that made cereal such a
huge success wasn't only in the
conditions of the times and publisher's
like Chapman and hall knew that it was
also in the genius of upstarts like the
one they chose.
A young writer named Charles Dickens,
Chapman and whole commission dickens to
write a few sporting stories to be
released with sketches done by the
artists,
Richard Seymour.
Altogether.
The project was called the posh,
the papers of the pickwick club or the
pickwick papers for sure.
The first part was horrendous failure.
Only 400 copies were sold after the
second part seem more committed suicide
and had to be replaced.
It wasn't until the fifth installment
when Dickins introduced a funny working
class character named Sam dweller that
the project struck gold,
whether it was a massive hit and after
the insistence of the readership,
the character was expanded throughout
the rest of the series launching its
sales from 400 to 40,000
for installment thanks to Dickens,
thanks to publishers like Chapman at
hall,
thanks to new printing presses and
liberal education in railways.
The serial novel dominated the world of
literature for the next 60 years,
and though most novels these days aren't
published,
like the pickwick papers were the genre
of serialization and it is a genre has
proven to be remarkably strong
flourishing and almost every
storytelling medium,
and this is no accident as Jennifer
Hayward notes in her incredible book
consuming pleasures.
The cereal is sort of the perfect form
for capitalism.
It captures readers with the promise of
more constantly delaying gratification,
and this makes it very commercially
effective and for the same reasons for
its appeal to mass market.
Consumers,
cereals have been castigated by critics
from the jump.
Before Dickens became a household name.
High Society reviewers raked his work
through the mud and the same kind of
treatment has been meted out on every
new incarnation of the CEO,
whether it's comics,
the serial films of the forties,
pulp novels,
soap operas,
or the endless sequels of Hollywood
blockbusters somewhere in the space.
This may be happening right now,
Star Wars olds.
I think an interesting place in the
history of the cereal,
a history that began with dickens and
like Dickens,
George Lucas is a special kind of
visionary going against the grain of
gritty realistic films that dominated
the 19 seventies.
Lucas devised a sweeping space epic with
broad themes influenced by the first
generation of film cereal like Flash
Gordon's,
and he was shrewd enough to understand
the advantages of serialization.
When it came up to doing the contract
for the film.
I knew that what I really had to do was
to protect the unwritten part,
the other two parts of the script.
The truth is that all cereals share a
group of common features and
characteristics going all the way back
to the pickwick papers like Dick and
stories in comic book universes and Star
Wars.
Cereals tend to feature giant casts of
characters and those characters tend to
resemble the mass public that consumes
them over time and often far too slowly.
Cereals trend toward diversity and
because of the massive casts,
cereals also have lots of subplots and
the main plots often feature a
surprising reversals and twists and
revelations that keep the audience
reaching for the next installment,
and this can make for cliche and
hackneyed storytelling like in the case
of soap operas,
which reconstructed the form to the
point of delaying all conclusions
infinitely,
but even soap operas demonstrate what is
probably the two most important features
of cereals,
the creation of interpretive communities
and their sensitivity to the audience's
desires.
A lot of the criticism of dickens work
centered around it's addictive quality
that the books took their readers out of
everyday life,
but the truth was the opposite.
Cereals created social bonds around the
content in question acting in this case
against the alienating effects of
capitalism and the industrial
revolution.
What's more within this space?
Even the lower classes had a forum for
engaging in political discourse
discussing what you thought about bleak
house or Oliver twist was a way of
debating social norms.
When the force awakens came out last
year,
it's emphasis on practical effects and
tactile imagery was as much a result of
the audience's referendum on the prequel
films as the expansion of the Sam Weller
character was for Dickens and the
pickwick papers,
but this relaunch of the star wars
cereals strikes me as something new
under the sun like soap operas.
It's promising to be endless like the
marvel film franchise.
It's promising to be connected and
intertwined,
but unlike most of the comic film,
so many of the stories and characters
have yet to be written and it's going to
be the first film cereal in which
subplots are going to be told as
dedicated features in their own run in
the anthology series.
This means opportunity for audiences.
The so called new golden age of TV is
almost exclusively down to serialized
shows that up their game because that's
what audiences demanded.
The new star wars franchise is primed to
explode in a thousand directions and
right now at the beginning is when we
can help to write the rules for what
kind of cereals that we want to see.
A new incarnation of serialization is
here,
fulfill 180 years after the pickwick
papers were first published.
That's a long history,
so why not mine it for all the best
qualities of this resilient and
receptive Sean.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I really want to recommend Jennifer
Hayward's book consuming pleasures.
If you want to know more about the
history of serialization,
not just the novels but in comics,
and so Barbara's.
It is required reading.
I loved it so much.
So I'll put a link in the description
below.
Also,
thank you to squarespace for sponsoring
this video.
If you don't know,
squarespace helps you make really sleek,
intuitive websites without having to
know coding.
They do all the work for you.
Really,
um,
if you can get a free domain name,
have you sign up for a year,
and if you go to squarespace.com
and use the offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
So thank you so much.
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.
Squarespace.
You should.